from migrating long distances
to avoiding predators the
synchronization of
large groups of animals is mesmerizing
to watch
and essential for their survival animals
create these displays by perceiving the
location
of neighbors but most drone swarms
like intel's have replicated large-scale
coordination using a different approach
a singular system that manages movement
and gps location
some groups of drones like swarmanoid a
fleet of flying
wheeled and climbing robots have been
able to organize without a central hub
but this type of decentralized
coordination has been difficult to
achieve
underwater until now
first researchers tackled how their
school of robotic fish
dubbed blue swarm would communicate
since radio signals are extremely weak
underwater
and gps coordinates are unavailable they
took
inspiration from two of the many ways
fish communicate with each other
vision and bioluminescence
two wide angle cameras created an almost
omnidirectional field of vision
and led lights toward the back of the
robot coordinated contact
researchers simplified the raw image
from the camera so that the fishbots
could easily
process their surroundings and make
quick decisions
by determining the size and location of
nearby lights
they could figure out the distance of a
neighboring fish
four fins on the bot inspired by the
surgeonfish
allowed for precise vertical and
horizontal movement
after perfecting the robot they created
algorithms to coordinate their behavior
in order to replicate milling swimming
in a collective circle
researchers devised a simple set of
rules
if a bluebot saw a robot they turned
slightly left
if there was no bot in their field of
vision they would turn right
ultimately researchers developed
multiple types of synchronized movements
including the ability for the blue swarm
to switch seamlessly between different
behaviors
their sequence of movements must be
programmed ahead of time since the bots
are not connected to a central computer
but the blue swarm isn't ready to be
deployed in the wild just yet
the led lights on the back aren't easy
to make out in light flooded coral reefs
or murkier environments
to use these fish spots for observation
in real life settings
researchers plan to swap the lights for
artificial schooling marks
with colors easily distinguishable from
their surroundings
using an led light on the front of the
robot in addition to the back leds
can help identify an angle a neighbor is
traveling
with schooling marks seeing more or less
of the band or a change in reflection
could signal to neighbors its
orientation
until then it's back to school for these
robot fish
you